welcome to this video raelia the name
nope I am maybe from Argentina that's
the flag at least but you never really
know yeah okay let's do the bogo at
least I know something about it so not
experimenting much and I try to play
play quickly here be 45 maybe we get
this super sharp h4 line which I I think
have not played on video much know it
takes this is some less less threatening
immediately I think you can go h6 not
completely sure g6 also a possible move
of course one of the two had quite
obviously but I wasn't sure okay I can
take on before maybe start with that the
whole line here is about black
destroying white some center and white
has active active pieces 7 and it's very
often a struggle between those those two
things okay so loopy 8 bishop if a dozen
move hmm ok i wonder if i should invest
the smooth a six or if that's not worth
at
not clear not clear to me wrong okay b5
night a five-night takes d4 no it's not
doing that okay so I'm taking this
chance to develop this bishop I get this
in now with the tempo slowing for night
see form if feasible not quite sure if I
want to play it immediately but yeah 94
it looks it looks quite quite useful
though yeah let's let's do that yeah we
had to put this interesting probably
back to the seven my idea is if possible
Queen B 6 and maybe a five getting count
to play against this and then in this
situation oh he wants to play Queen d3
as something to take very seriously okay
one thing though is I can't a key 5 SC 1
hangs I wonder I wonder if this is the
way to go Knight e5 he's got Queen d5
though I can yeah I mean things i have
to take it come on if i take it Queen d5
all right at six well tricky sorry about
the noise with the chair tricky business
yeah rook takes rook c1 is simple
average this is just completely not
working well 95 is also having the nice
positive effect 23s prevented the
question is Queen takes d5 is there
something great I was thinking Bishop f6
is good okay something entirely
different I can go wish Bishop age 6
this idea
don't know the ship I can just clip in
96 96 Bishop cheeks I had to tell I
don't want to allow to to to severe time
trouble note that i always have a bishop
h4 is an interesting intermediate move
which is quite important here i was
thinking here as well actually yeah
yeah in most of my videos I've played 46
against nie bede to the main reason is
that i did this line this line is the
the main thing that i have in my book
against night BTW to but it is it is
very complicated and i have forgotten
most of the things that i had analyzed
and now as I was wrapping up my book and
I'm really finished I only have to send
it again to the publisher it's kind of a
step-by-step process you think you're
ready and then they say ah you know
there is a little thing here and there
and then well again you do some changes
and you send it again and so on so I'm
basically done with final little things
are still are still in the works okay so
it's going to regain this pawn before
now immediately push it yeah maybe
whoopsie to getting active play Bishop
d44 and g3 am dropping bags was the idea
just getting this active move in so hmm
can I use this Bishop pollution somehow
don't see don't see how so we should
hide morning d for not sure that this
would help me in any way this this he
can go back from kfor i don't know i
only have 50 seconds seven i started
with a really good time advantage but it
tickled tickled away
hmm i wonder if he can do this this I
didn't think it's yeah even that is an
interesting they are interesting he
played it played it in a very
interesting way I want to open up here
again steph 206 row 27 this is IDM
you have a point down unfortunately
check
Jeff I don't tell me I cannot cannot
cover the pawns here Jesus no this is
this is unfair is this is really it
should be a draw and don't elect one
tempo to draw this this is a shame
really like I don't believe it I don't
believe it yeah this is it still drawn
not actually losing this is really a bit
really a bit much I was clearly better
the whole game and that has screwed it
up at least I should draw it yeah the
turkey it's difficult difficult to see
how I should should play here ships III
mmm something like that I was thinking
that that also here I should do I should
have something with the active rooks but
he's always covering this and this this
was a misjudgment yeah i mean okay thats
its losing it isn't is this is very this
is very difficult really but I managed
to manage to do it so how do I actually
draw this Jack game I just I just have
to I probably screwed up with tempo
somewhere where did I wait you to make
this mistake is this is this the mistake
too
they need to start with this then
probably that the drawing mechanism is
of course that either get this and I
will get get pawns to get the pawns
rolling chief five first and probably
yeah that's a draw simply for some
reason the way I played it it wasn't a
draw where did I screw it up this one
okay I didn't have any time but still so
I have to start a I can check I can
check first it is still a draw kingi
King g3 is also a draw Josh aqui here
Jackie maybe it's still it's still mad
this is losing look g1 as a draw which
is kind of surprising
Teague's they always have a check of
course on the king yeah it's a silly
drives I was really a bit mystified why
all of a sudden I was I was losing rook
rook c5 was a was a stupid move I just
like I just like the temp I mean I lost
some time at the position now is some is
also losing yeah this is roxy 5s really
stupid rook to e1 is the draw edit this
is this is to act of him to be losing
but yeah of course I I had to had to
play better here because here I'm I'm
better to some extent but to what extent
the compass on 0.6 is this kind of
things probably here I have something
like this and just just playing it with
the activity maybe try to use the king
yeah that's probably right i have d to
also like d2 and then run over with a
king very difficult to hold for what
yeah you know I really i didn't i didn't
assess this right i thought that the
rooks on the second-ranked there are
some ideas but it's really just so
safely protected okay well thanks for
watching